ski and snowboarding season is underway
at lee canyon and i took a trip up the
hill to get the details
on their new safety protocols and to hit
the slopes
jim it's good to see you it's good to
see that the the hill is open
uh things are a little bit different
this year because of covet 19 you have
some safety protocols in a place what do
you have going on
absolutely nice to see you so yeah there
are some safety protocols because of the
pandemic
one is making sure that there are
parking reservations
by everybody and that's the one way
we're controlling capacity up here
you'll see all the safety protocols
masks
hand sanitizer stations everywhere
physical distancing promoted you know
throughout
and what's great about skiing and
snowboarding in the trails is once you
get out there
it's naturally physically distant so
it's great to get out
you know into nature now this weekend
it's a very special weekend with a big
fundraiser going on for the nevada donor
network tell us about what's happening
this weekend that's right so it's the
sixth annual chris ruby cup
and it's a race that we put on
but it's a fun run so all levels can do
it ages
7 to 87 and we all come out here for a
great cause
which is raising awareness for the
nevada donor network and what they do
for organization donation
we've kind of spread it out and done it
a little bit virtually this year
by having 40 people on friday saturday
and sunday now
i've been in las vegas since 1995. this
is my first time on the mountain
can you can you show me around a little
bit absolutely let's go take a look so
right now we're in the bristlecone
uh of our new 10 000 square foot
facility the hillside lodge
we love it it added like a new
experience to
coming up here to lee canyon i noticed
the key thing is that we got we have a
full service bar which is a nest
that's a necessity when it comes to
skiing and snowboarding absolutely now
the view out here is spectacular
we'll go outside yeah let's take a look
at the view go check this out it's the
million dollar views that we're looking
at
jim this outdoor area anyone can come
sit out here anyone can come out here
that's what this deck is for do a bask
in the sun
check out the skiers and snowboarders
and enjoy yourself okay now speaking of
skiing the last time i skied
ronald reagan was president the last
time i got on a pair of skis
uh can i get on some today the
technology might be a little bit
different
but let's go get you booted up
[Music]
this is stu and stu has the privilege of
being my ski
instructor today stu how's it going
buddy it's going very well and we're
going to have a good time
just put on our right ski okay
i'm feeling good with one ski oh yeah
absolutely we all do give yourself a
little push or glide
still how long have you been skiing i
started when i was 46 and i'm almost 79
now you're almost 79
yeah you look like you're 46. all right
i'm ready for two i think you want two
though
okay here we go there we go give
ourselves a little shuffle
and a stop now stop
what stop look out kid you know get a
little bigger wedge so you're going
slower
a little bigger a little bigger okay a
little bigger
excellent the impressive thing is that
you're looking backwards
[Music]
what's the trick to getting on the
trailer probably the trick is
not getting on the chair if the trick is
getting off the chair get ready
get ready now stand straight up let's
stand up lean forward
[Applause]
one more run
all right here we go
yeah feel it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was still it's the old tv
switcheroo
i'm not ready for the double diamonds
you kidding me no no no wow i'm glad
that that was
your story yeah you just say it you're
not good on skis
no i would have been doing the
beginner's classes with the children
that's why they have a full service bar
yeah i was asking so you can ski and
snowboard under the influence
that makes it so much better when you
fall it really does i just feel like
that's a little dangerous but you know
to each his own right
you can go to lee canyon lv for more
information las vegas now